hey guys greg knuckles here and today
we're talking about rep speed
specifically how fast should you be
trying to push the bar
if you're trying to get as strong as you
possibly can
um this is something that's been debated
for a while
as far back as 30 years ago guys like
fred hatfield
were saying every set every rep as fast
as you possibly can for the best
strength gains
people with more of a bodybuilding
background have been
saying oh you should slow down your rep
speed because that will give you more
time under tension
more time under tension means bigger
muscles bigger muscles mean stronger
muscles
um so there's there's been a bit of a
of a dispute there with the power
lifting and weightlifting community
being more on the side of you should
push every rep as fast as possible
and people with more of a bodybuilding
background typically saying
no it's it's okay to slow it down or
perhaps even better to slow it down a
little bit
so a recent study was published uh this
past may
um called maximal intended velocity
training induces
greater gains in bench press performance
than deliberately slower
half velocity training um and so i'm
guessing
you can uh surmise the main results just
from the title
so spoiler alert whatever um
but anyway that's basically what it
found but so kind of some background
first
the uh the theory behind
faster training being better is that
as you produce more force you have to
recruit bigger and stronger muscle fiber
so it's not like
your muscle fibers can produce this much
like an individual muscle fiber can
produce this much force
but then under a heavier load it like
that individual fiber produces more
force it's that each individual fiber
has a certain amount of force it can
produce
and so as you need to produce more and
more force you have to produce
or you have to recruit more and more
fibers um
and there's an order in how they're
recruited basically the smallest weakest
fibers
are recruited first typically slow
twitch fibers
and then the larger the larger stronger
faster twitch fibers
are progressively recruited and then the
biggest largest strongest
are recruited at the very end so
uh the thinking being if you have
a given weight uh force is mass times
acceleration
so all other things being equal if you
move it faster you produce more force
so you're recruiting more of those big
strong muscle fibers
and so that's going to get you stronger
faster
and that sounds great in theory except
for the fact
that most research to this point
didn't really support that or at least
it didn't unambiguously
um some studies had found that faster
trainer faster
training was better others had found
that there really wasn't much of a
difference
um but there were some methodological
problems with the past research
one big thing the biggest thing probably
is a lot of the previous studies had
looked at training to failure
and basically found that there wasn't
too much difference
that rep speed made when you're pushing
each set to failure
but so a big problem with that just
right off is
regardless of how fast you're trying to
push the bar if you're going to failure
all of your reps at the end are going to
be slow anyways
so even though they were trying to
control for bar speed
or at least like provide lifting cadence
they didn't actually measure bar speed
to determine
whether there was actually whether
that's what was actually making a
difference
and really really the biggest thing you
can take away from that research
was that as long as you're pushing to
failure
and producing similar levels of fatigue
you're going to gain
basically the same amount of size and
strength and that's that's pretty well
supported
um so what this study wanted to do
is specifically focus on training not to
failure
so when you're pushing to failure you're
not
you're not necessarily controlling for
volume and intensity but when you're
staying farther away from failure you
can
so that's what they were doing in this
study and um
so they started with like sets of six to
eight at sixty percent which you could
probably do for like twelve to fifteen
fresh
uh and worked up to sets of like three
to four at eighty percent which you
could probably do for
about eight reps fresh um so even with
the slower lifting cadence
uh it still wouldn't be to failure so
the volume was the same the intensity
was the same
uh the only difference was how fast the
people were actually pushing the bar
and they actually used something really
interesting to assign weights for the
day they
they used bar speed which previous
research had found
correlated very strongly with your
strength for the day
uh so just to throw a number at you um
previous research had found that if
you're moving a weight at about
0.79 meters per second
that's pretty close to about 60 percent
of your one rep max
and so basically what the researchers
would do is during your warm-up sets you
would push
every rep as fast as possible and then
as soon as you hit the heaviest weight
that you could move
at .79 meters per second they would be
like okay this is
your sixty percent wait for the day and
that's a really interesting way
of um assigning weights for a given day
because like let's say
let's say you bench like 225 or
something and you're doing
a 16 week percentage based training
program
it's problematic to base things off of
an initial percent because
hopefully you're getting stronger over
those 16 weeks
so by using velocity that's something
that you can use to say like
hey this is about eighty percent of how
strong i am
today or like this is seventy percent of
how strong i am
today not how strong i was 16 weeks ago
or whenever i hit my all-time pr
anyway uh so what they did is uh let's
say sixty percent
uh you can push it point seven nine
meters per second
um so the group that was doing the
maximal intensive
intended velocity training would work up
to the heaviest weight they could
push at that speed and then every single
every single rep they would push as hard
as they possibly could
um and the half velocity group would
work up as fast as they could to um
to a weight they could push it 0.79
meters per second
but then they had a screen in front of
them that was providing visual and audio
feedback
to help them push it at a rate of 0.4
meters per second
to control for bar speed so bar speed is
the only thing different
volume and intensity are the same so
they train for
six weeks and um kind of the eye popping
thing
and i'll um i'll flash graphs up for you
is that across the board
um the maximal velocity group
had essentially twice the gains
so they gained um about
18 percent on their bench press versus
10
for the other group another thing they
looked at is um
speed with different absolute
intensities so
um they looked at
how heavy of weights you can move
at 0.8 meters per second or slower
so that's about 60 percent or heavier
like relatively heavy weights
and in the max velocity group there was
about a 36
improvement versus about 17 in the half
velocity group
um and then for lighter loads loads that
you can move at 0.8 meters per second or
faster
there's about 11 11 and a half percent
improvement versus a four and a half
percent improvement
so across the board the max velocity
group did better
in terms of strength gains one other
interesting thing to point out
going back to the
velocities at given absolute loads so
both groups had larger improvements
in bar speed with relatively heavy loads
than they did with relatively light
loads and um from there we can see
something about training transference
um so one of the first things a lot of
people will say is like
oh if if you're trying to get your
vertical leap up you need to squat more
and that's absolutely true to a point
but after that point the transference
will be less
so you're like let's say you're a double
body weight squatter
or thereabouts um your body is a
relatively light load
that if you're going to be jumping very
high at all you're going to be moving
your body much faster
than 0.8 meters per second for a
vertical leap test
so moving relatively heavy weights
really improves your ability to move
relatively heavy weights fast
but it doesn't really say that much or
it doesn't do
quite as much for moving relatively
light things fast like say
your body or like if you're a shot
putter a 16 pound ball
okay so guys those are really the high
points um i did a slightly more
extensive write-up from my blog
you can find the link in the description
as well as the link to the study i'm
referencing
in addition if this is a topic that
interests you i'm going to link
laden jovanovich's blog he's
he's someone who's much more of an
expert on this topic
than i am and he he has a lot to say
about it so if this is something
that interests you and you want to use
speed-based training to regulate
to regulate your lifting for a given day
or for a training cycle
i would highly recommend you check out
his stuff anyway so guys that's all i
have to say
signing out don't forget to
like and subscribe and check out my blog
and all that cool stuff
anyway thanks